Alec Baldwin sure it is let's talk about
this a picture on his Instagram one year
to the day that he incidentally shot the
director dude that was a year ago she
got nice arms um I was gonna say that
right absolutely amazing arms and so his
he posts just a picture of her behind
the camera and then just the caption one
year ago today
Savage had
come on
probably doesn't have him anymore come
on can someone explain to me what the
[ __ ] is wrong with Alec Baldwin is he
out of his [ __ ] mind of his [ __ ]
mind one year another day dot dot dot I
killed someone
it's crazy like does he live in a world
where he doesn't realize that he does
something wrong I think he does okay
he's completely delusional I think he's
convinced himself I didn't do anything
that's the only way he can live with
yourself he convinced himself he didn't
even pull the trigger and then the FBI
was like yeah you did yeah yeah and then
he had to go oh I guess isn't he a big
anti-gun guy because if so this is the
perfect time for him to be like son this
is why I'm anti-gun I killed somebody on
a movie set because guns are dangerous
he doesn't want to take any credit so he
can get sued
but he just makes his own reality that's
a lesson you taught me I think is
actually very admirable what does that
mean it seems kind of insulting
that's what you said that's what you
told me to do sometimes when things are
bad you just make your own reality in
your head where things are actually
better than they were and then you
believe that I never said that too much
that seems you're making your own
reality right now
remember he didn't say that that's why I
was bolded it that's a good response
some bad [ __ ] happened and he was like
nope I actually didn't do the bad thing
moving on
I don't think I'd make a fake reality I
don't know when I've ever said that what
I will do is adjust a fake reality that
is inspired by my insecurities and I
think a lot of people live in the bubble
of their insecurities
people don't like me I'm not good at
this whatever like that and I don't
think that ever helps you but what Alec
Baldwin lives in a bubble of his
confidence or something like that his
ego illusion like delusion I mean this
is crazy yeah this is crazy nobody was
like is he gonna address it you reminded
us of it yeah or just a better caption
constantly thinking of this fateful day
like I pray for the families constantly
something like that have more and then
the first comment is stay strong my
friend thinking about you and all those
affected by this terrible I said that
the Leslie Jordan who is that who is
Leslie Jordan who the [ __ ] who is that
can you be Leslie Jordan like there's a
bunch of fake ones
what is this oh the gay guy oh no this
guy's adorable oh shoot wait he just
died today
hey God hey thinking of you my friend
yeah oh man oh shoot yeah yeah he's from
your favorite show Will and Grace
there's no way he typed that out oh yeah
he's too old he died today in a car
crash get the [ __ ] out of here was he
driving that happened how does that
happen okay Cheryl Hines gave him the
hearts that's nice okay who's Daryl
Hines again
heartbreaking it is heartbreaking
sending lots of Hearts that's fair that
wasn't the real one she never boots and
then everyone that's not blue checks is
like I'm not exactly sure how to react
to this post it's on the blue chat
comments are embarrassing finish the
heading one year ago today what
you're a bold one
you're a bulldog is good I mean one year
ago today just sounds like an
anniversary like that just sounds like
hey I got married one year ago today I
don't understand why it's like it seems
celebratory this guy's a weirdo man
this guy's a [ __ ] weirdo did he take
it down all right that's it was on
Instagram right now wow as we speak one
year ago I caught a body yeah oh yeah
maybe he's saying like he was he might
be making a movie now like people are
acting up a bit yeah
a lot of people are listening to him
he's not getting his way on set and he's
like all right just wanna let y'all know
365 days ago and isn't the movie back in
production
oh if it comes out I'm not I'm pretty
sure no it is yeah Dove sent us a link
yeah you got to get in that why not
I don't support that shoot back got
another season of uh Sons of Anarchy to
shoot this one yeah oh sick
that's a pretty good joke I wish I
didn't stutter but yeah yeah
but the structure was great